mit kristallklarem Wasser und
atemberaubender Natur gilt die
thailändische Insel kutao als ein
Paradies für Touristen und junge
Backpacker was allerdings viele nicht
wissen unter Einheimischen ist die Insel
lediglich als Todesinsel bekannt und
dafür sind zahlreiche verschwundene und
ermordete Touristen Täter wurden
entweder gar nicht oder nur sehr
fragwürdig ermittelt ich habe mich auf
den Weg gemacht und eine Woche auf Koh
Tao gelebt viel Spaß mit diesem Video
und damit jo Leute was geht herzlich
willkommen zum neuen Video heute wird
glaube ich ziemlich interessant kurze
kleine Vorgeschichte an dieser
traumhaften Kulisse hier ich befinde
mich aktuell noch auf Koh Samui wir
fahren jetzt allerdings also ich bin ja
mittlerweile nicht mehr alleine und
Kumpel von mir der auf Bali war hat mich
besucht und jetzt sind wir halt noch
eine Zeit zusammen unterwegs auf jeden
Fall ist das jetzt hier so gesehen der
Hafen von Koh Samui auf jeden Fall eine
richtig geile Insel oder einer der
helfen steckt auf jeden Fall die letzten
Videos ab falls es noch nicht gemacht
habe und wir fahren jetzt von hier aus
eineinhalb Stunden mit dem Speedboot auf
die Insel Ko Tao das soll eigentlich
auch so die schönste Insel hier sein
allerdings ich bin jetzt auch schon eine
Weile hier und ich habe mit ziemlich
vielen gesprochen auch mit vielen Locals
und gerade die Locals sagen wenn du
sagst jo wir fahren noch nach kutao was
was wollt ihr denn da da würde ich ja
niemals hinfahren und als ich das so zum
ersten Mal gehört habe dachte ich so hä
warum nicht das soll doch voll cool sein
man muss einfach dazu sagen in den
deutschen Medien war das nicht wirklich
vielleicht liegt daran weil bis jetzt
noch keine deutschen Leute dort
verschwunden sind aber seit ungefähr 10
bis 12 Jahren verschwinden immer mal
wieder Leute auf ganz komische Art und
Weise dort und werden dann tot
aufgefunden ich bin auch selber großer
True Crime Fan also ich habe mir ganz
viele Podcast an hat mich jetzt mit dem
Thema auch ein bisschen beschäftigt und
ich muss sagen es ist wirklich echt ein
bisschen gruselig gut ich bin jetzt
nicht alleine und ich habe auch keine
Angst oder so aber auf der Insel sind
echt sehr sehr viele verrückte Sachen
passiert ich versuche euch das ein
bisschen auf zu erkennen in diesem Video
der berühmteste falsch stammt aus dem
Jahr 2014 dort sind da zwei Briten
ermordet worden nachts und am Strand tot
aufgefunden worden die Insel ist auch
überhaupt nicht groß das heißt wir
können uns auch diese Stelle anschauen
wo die gefunden wurden und bis heute ist
höchst umstritten wer die eigentlich
umgebracht hat es wurden zwei Asiaten
dann zur Todesstrafe verurteilt
mittlerweile allerdings in den
lebenslängliche Haftstrafe umgewandelt
wurde viele hier sagen auf der Insel
gibt es so eine Art inselmafia also eine
Familie die da wirklich viel Macht hat
und ich will jetzt ach keine Ahnung ich
will auch keine Spekulationen aufstellen
aber es gibt ganz viele verschiedene
Theorien ich bin auf jeden Fall mal
gespannt wir werden dort einiges
Unternehmen unter anderem auch dieses
berühmte Pub crawling was auch die
beiden gemacht haben die dann umgebracht
wurden kurz zur Erklärung was popcorning
eigentlich ist man trifft sich mit
vielen anderen jungen Leuten erstmal in
einer Bar auf haben wir dafür jetzt
umgerechnet ungefähr 15 € pro Person
bezahlt dann bekommt man so ein Tanktop
alle sehen halt gleich aus geht damit
100 200 Leuten durch verschiedene Bars
bekommt auch Freigetränke macht
verschiedene Aktivitäten und am Ende
landet das ganze dann entweder in einem
Club oder noch in der Bar werde ich aber
alles sehen und so wie ich meine
Recherche genommen habe haben das auch
diese beiden Opfer Hanna und David
heißen sie gemacht bevor sie halt dann
am nächsten Morgen tot aufgefunden
wurden also die Insel ist hier nur als
Toteninsel oder mörderinsel bekannt
klingt doch gut ab geht's um euch die
Geschehnisse auf Guthaben noch schnell
ein bisschen näher zu bringen hier mal
eine grobe Übersicht einiger Fälle muss
dazu sagen es sind aber längst nicht
alle aus den letzten zehn Jahren noch
mal schnell der bekannteste Fall Hanna
witheridge und David Müller wurden im
September 2014 in den Morgenstunden nach
einer Partynacht tot am Strand gefunden
der Fall ging extrem durch Medien
weltweit und auf die örtliche Polizei
wurde enormer Druck ausgeübt endlich
Täter zu finden verurteilt wurden dann
zwei rumänische Wanderarbeiter die
Prozesse dazu sind aber höchst fraglich
ihr könnt euch ja gerne mal Podcast
Folgen anschauen Ludmilla wurde am 8
januar 2016 in einem Swimmingpool in der
Sunset Bar am Siri Beach schon
aufgefunden er soll wohl ertrunken sein
Ermittlungen wurden dann direkt
eingestellt Christina ebenfalls eine
britische Urlauberin starb im Januar
2015 sein nachdem sie Antibiotika mit
Alkohol vermischt hatte das war die
offizielle Begründung des Todes aber es
wird auch nicht weiter ermittelt hier
wurde aber noch ein Mann von einer
Überwachungskamera aufgezeichnet der
wohl ihr Zimmer in der Nacht noch
verlassen hat und er wurde nicht von
unten wie dieser Mann aussah kein Plan
Nik Piercen wurde am neues Tag 2014 tot
im Meer treiben gefunden er soll von
einer Krippe gestürzt sein seine Eltern
glauben weiß aber nicht und denken ihr
wurde ermordet Valentina Novus sinova
verschwand aus ihrem Hostel sie hat
nicht ausgecheckt und dann wurde nachher
gesucht bis heute ist sie nicht mehr
aufgetaucht die offizielle Version der
Polizei ist dass sie beim Freitauchen im
Meer ums Leben gekommen ist Dimitri
profse wurde ebenfalls am Neujahrstag
2015 tot in seinem Bungalow gefunden
offizielle Version er hat Selbstmord
begangen das komische nur seine Hände
waren hinter seinem Rücken gefesselt und
zu guter Letzt sie wurde 8 Tage nachdem
sie ihre Mutter erzählt hat sie macht
jetzt auf dem Heimweg tot im Wald
gefunden offizielle Version auch hier
Suizid aber die Eltern glauben das nicht
und ich muss auch sagen natürlich kann
das mal vorkommen dass Touristen
irgendwie vor Ort ums Leben kommen aber
diese große Menge und das waren ja
längst nicht alle Fälle in dieser kurzen
Zeit ist schon echt komisch vor allem
auf dieser kleinen Insel die Insel ist
wie gesagt wirklich nicht groß so jetzt
erstmal aufs Boot
das ist übrigens Tristan hallo hallo
alles gut und wir fahren jetzt hier mit
den Speedbooten super das wird eine
schaukelige Angelegenheit dann ging es
also los von Koh Samui nach Kota mit dem
Speedboot war wirklich ziemlich wackelig
viele Wellen trotzdem eineinhalb Stunden
gegen relativ schnell rum und hier kann
man dann schon sehen die Insel ist
wirklich groß man kann auch an einem Tag
zu Fuß komplett einmal rumgehen erst
dachte ich mein Rucksack wäre geklaut
worden aber ich habe ihn dann doch
gefunden
okay Leute wir sind auf jeden Fall
angekommen so sieht's aus
auf jeden Fall schon ganz nice fahren
wir erstmal zu unserer Unterkunft so
jetzt geht's erstmal mit deutschen
Verkehrsmitteln zum Hotel oder Resort
wie auch immer das Gute ist aber die
Sonne scheint wenigstens wieder
[Musik]
also hier ist jetzt zum Beispiel ein
Foto mit allen Personen die hier in den
letzten zehn Jahren auf mysteriöse Art
und Weise entweder verschwunden oder
halt umgebracht wurden und die hier das
ist diese Henna und er hier das ist halt
der bekannteste Fall und auch wenn man
das googelt findet man zahlreiche
Berichte dazu auch auf Touristen sicher
ist und also ein Quatsch also wir sehen
das auf jeden Fall als weniger schlimm
an wir hatten auf jeden Fall keine Angst
sind glaube ich zumindest oder hast du
Angst aber man muss sagen es ist auf
jeden Fall schon sehr mysteriös wenn
auch so einer kleinen Insel in so einem
kurzen Zeitraum so viele Leute weg sind
das war der Sache auf dem Grund gehen
ich vermissteriös wir machen heute
kleinen Inseltrip und schauen mal was
passiert das ist übrigens der Strand wo
wir sind das ist dieser Beach und gerade
ist Apple erstmal gab es auf jeden Fall
Frühstück und dann haben wir uns mit dem
Roller auf dem Weg gemacht hier auf der
rechten Seite ist komplett das
Teilgebiet und da sind auch eigentlich
fast alle Verbrechen oder Vorfälle
passiert Inhalt Bungalows oder wie auch
immer also das Teilgebietes wirklich der
Hotspot der Insel aber wirklich ein sehr
schöner Strand mir geht's jetzt hoch zum
360 Grad das soll wohl der beste
Aussichtspunkt der ganzen Insel sein und
es soll sich lohnen deswegen sind wir
hier hingefahren und schauen uns das
jetzt mal an es ist ein bisschen wandern
wow
angekommen wir mussten gerade noch 50
Watt bezahlen hier geht es jetzt noch
hoch wow
okay krass schon geil das hier unten
nennt sich Shark bei weil es dort sogar
Haie gibt die bekannteste Art die Leute
herumschwimmen ist der weiße Hai der
Spaß okay wir gehen jetzt tatsächlich
jetzt zu stark bei runter und wollen uns
ein und dann schnorcheln gehen der
letzte tödliche Eingriff in Thailand ist
allerdings schon 23 Jahre her also alles
gut von der Natur sieht's ein bisschen
aus wie ein Teutoburger Wald oder
das erste mal in meinem ganzen Leben
dass ich andere Fische sehe außer
Balearen
[Musik]
irgendwie ist sie auch noch mal weg wo
ich mich so richtig drüber freue dass
ich eine Schildkröte gesehen habe weil
das war die erste Schildkröte die ich in
meinem gesamten Leben gesehen habe
richtig geile Schildkröte und jetzt
zurück zum Thema so sind hier auf Kuta
übrigens die typischen Restaurants aus
aber das ist auch auf allen anderen
Insel ähnlich kann man aushalten bevor
wir uns dann am Abend zum Pub crawling
gegeben haben was ja zum Beispiel Henna
und David auch gemacht haben haben wir
uns erstmal auf den Fundort angeschaut
der war auch wirklich nicht weit von
unserem Hotel Weg gefunden wurden die
beiden ja auch im Beach wo sich halt
alles abspielen ich würde sagen wir
schauen uns das jetzt mal von Namen an
für mich wie so ein crime Podcast aber
bin ich ja gar nicht ich habe aber auf
jeden Fall den Podcast gehört dass Sie
hier rumgeklatscht sind und dann
irgendwie
nachts genau hier glaube ich war das
wenn ich ich jetzt recht erinnere
gefunden wurden also die lagen hier und
das Wasser kam auch und hat halt so
Spuren verwischt und das war noch übelst
viele Schaulustige hier also man hat
halt auch direkt am nächsten Tag Fotos
auf Social Media und so gefunden und das
krasse ist wenn man recherchiert findet
man sogar noch teilweise solche Fotos
oder die Fotos davon ich habe es ja auch
schon öfter erwähnt es gibt ja auf so
eine Insel Mafia oder einfach so eine
Gang auch Polizeibeamte die hier einfach
unfassbar viel Macht haben und wenn man
sich so Dokus anschaut und auch im Forum
rumliegt da steht halt überall das ist
der Sohn von einem Polizeibeamten oder
von unserem Höheren Tier hier halt
gewesen sein soll und das halt so
verschleiert wurde also es gibt auf
jeden Fall super viele Fälle hier wo man
sich fragt es kann doch nicht sein dass
immer nur gesagt wird okay die haben
sich irgendwie selbst umgebracht und
dann wird der Fall abgehakt man kann
halt nichts machen und ein Täter wird
halt auch nie ermittelt also das ist
schon alles sehr du BIOS gut ist jetzt 9
Jahre her aber trotzdem echt sehr sehr
interessanter Fall auch für mich weil
ich habe mir super viele Podcast immer
an und den Fall fand ich auf jeden Fall
sehr sehr krass nur das Ding ist hier
ist auch direkt ein Hotel und
ja gut hat anscheinend immer was
mitbekommen hier kann man die Stelle
noch mal von oben sehen also genau hier
war das sind auch die Fotos die es alle
im Internet gibt in Deutschland stand
jetzt natürlich so ein Kreuz aber das
finde ich jetzt hier nicht da auf dem
Boden ist ein Pfeil der was zu bedeuten
hat weiß ich nicht okay hier hinter ist
jetzt doch noch so ein Grab oder so aber
ich glaube dass er nichts damit zu tun
sondern eher irgendwas mit dem
Buddhismus ich weiß auch nicht genau was
da steht aber dafür habe ich euch hier
kannst du mal kommentieren wir sind hier
gerade in den Gassen von Kuta unterwegs
da vorne ist das Papp wo dieses
popcorning startet was auch die beiden
die ich euch da gezeigt habe gemacht
haben das Gute ist mein Kollege Tristan
der trinkt nix das heißt du passt heute
Abend schön auf wir sind ja auf jeden
Fall jetzt bei dieser popcorn-party das
ist Wasser mit Eiswürfeln habe sogar
alle zwei Tage und ich habe es insgesamt
sogar dreimal mitgemacht der Ablauf ist
immer der gleiche man trifft sich in der
ersten Bar dann gibt's eine kleine
Ansage für den Veranstaltern trinkt dort
was und geht dann ins Queens cabarett da
ist dann so eine ladyboyshow
[Musik]
dann geht's weiter zum Strand dort ist
eine Feuershow überall gibt's halt was
zu trinken und da werden so kleine
Spielchen gespielt
[Musik]
zurück in die erste Bar und dann circa
gegen 12 bis 1 Uhr geht es entweder in
die fischball Bar oder in die AC Bar wo
wir an diesem Abend auch waren und die
AC Bar ist auch der letzte Ort an dem
Hannah und David zusammenlebend gesehen
worden sind okay Leute also wir sind
jetzt mittlerweile schon 5 Tage hier auf
kutao haben einmal die Unterkunft
gewechselt sind jetzt mittlerweile in
einem anderen Haus und haben in den fünf
Tagen auf jeden Fall einiges erlebt wir
waren jeden Tag unterwegs bis 23 Uhr
nachts abends irgendwo oder unten in der
Stadt also die Stadt ist von hier aus
einfach runter oder muss wirklich sagen
kotao ist gerade für Leute in meinem
Alter jetzt oder ich sag mal für 18 bis
30-Jährige die noch Bock haben viel von
der Welt zu sehen auf jeden Fall eine
richtig geile Insel die man schon mal
gesehen haben muss und unserer Meinung
nach braucht man hier auch überhaupt
keine Angst haben vor irgendwas klar das
Internet ist voll mit irgendwelchen
Warnung und so dass man hier besser
nicht hinfahren sollte weil das und das
passieren kann das einzige was man sagen
kann also ich habe zwei oder drei mal
mitbekommen dass irgendwie so
Streitigkeiten entstehen in der Bar oder
so
[Musik]
und natürlich gibt es hier viele
Einheimische die sich vielleicht
teilweise auch darüber abpacken dass es
hier so viele Touristen gibt aber die
verdienen hier natürlich auch ihren
Lebensunterhalt mit Touristen und
solange man sich nicht mit einheimischen
irgendwie in die Haare bekommen wegen
irgendwas muss man hier denke ich auch
nichts zu befürchten haben eine Sache
die ich aber noch ansprechen wollte und
zwar ist das in der thailändischen
Kultur so hast du das mal gehört mit
diesem Gesicht verlieren Tristan wenn
Thailänder die dieses Gesicht verlieren
wenn die irgendwas Vorhaben wenn du dich
z.B in der Basis sitzen willst und dann
ist dein Platz frei und du gehst einfach
hin und ein Thailänder hat gerade seinen
Freunden gesagt jo lass dahin setzen und
du warst dann praktisch vor ihm da dann
[__] den das also er geht dann der
Konfrontation aus dem Weg aber ihn [__]
das ab und er will dann irgendwie sein
Gesicht nicht verlieren und will Dir
dann irgendwie schaden also das klingt
total crazy aber teilweise ist es
wirklich so dass wenn man irgendwie auch
wenn man es gar nicht merkt im
Thailänder so in dieser Form Schaden
zufügt dass es ihnen dann abfuckt und er
das halt wieder so gesehen gut machen
möchte könnte ja gern mal googeln
Gesicht verlieren in Thailand das ist
halt komplett einfach eine andere Kultur
und ich könnte mir vorstellen gut das
ist jetzt eine weit hergeholte these
aber das einige dieser vermissten Fälle
hier auf der Insel eventuell darauf
zurückzuführen sind abschließend total
war richtig geil ich bin froh dass wir
hingefahren sind und morgen geht's
weiter ich bedanke mich fürs zuschauen
Leute abonniert sehr sehr gerne den
Kanal und wir sehen uns haut rein
Instagram Alex wie tschüss